let's take a brief look at how to think
about submitting your photographs as
potential cover art in their
presentations the first thing that's
essential is for you to study the
journal layout to which you are
submitting your image how they might be
placed in the particular cover format
most covers these days are full bleeds
that is the image takes up the whole
cover and is therefore vertical some of
them still have let's say rectangle
places within the larger vertical format
but most of them are bleeds at this
point so you have to think about that
when you do submit an idea for a cover
think about where the journals logo is
placed where additional text might be
dropped you have to take all these
things into consideration to help the
art director decide whether or not the
image is good enough for a cover but I
do suggest not submitting a cover idea
with the journal logo just let the folks
at the journal use their imaginations
let's start with something I did fairly
recently here I was given a number of
samples of material they're all
fabricated pieces that respond
differently to pressure trying to think
of how in the world i was going to come
up with an interesting cover design so i
decided to play around with the shapes
here i'm using my flatbed scanner and
i'm adding a few pieces here and there
and finally wound up with this
composition which i thought had the
potential of being considered for this
particular journal cover and I did
digitally add a gradient to the
background as you can see in the end yes
it did make a cover which is always nice
but do keep in mind it's not just the
image that will get you on the cover
it's the science in the article that
informs the journal selection maybe some
other things as well which none of us
are privy to so it's not just the
aesthetics mostly about the importance
of the research which should be the case
here's another example which you've seen
before showing the flexible circuitry
imprinted on transparent material and
again we were delighted to get the cover
of the journal probably because of the
importance of the science and by the way
that journal now has another format
where the cover art takes a completely
different shape than what you're seeing
here so again it's very important to
match your images format with the
journals format for this image another
one that you've seen before it still is
one of my favorites after all these
years bit unusual because I don't
usually like old stuff but they used it
for the cover of a textbook in chemistry
after all this is very very much about
chemistry and notice how they crop the
image to fit the format and of course I
gave the publisher permission to do that
and here this image was made by the
researchers hundreds of miles from my
studio but we communicated closely
through email with my making suggestions
on how to photograph and light the word
in this next image the researchers
shined a laser on to the container with
no additional room light and we see new
material showing up we couldn't see it
before because those balls have the same
index of refraction as the solution in
which they were floating that's the
point of this research the researchers
wanted to show this image with a hand in
place suggesting that the laser is
turned off ready to be turned on and i
said no please no hands I believe that
hands generally distract and detract
from the rest of the image it's just
another distraction please don't use
hands so I suggested starting with a
container under a lamp as before and
then take another picture with just the
laser shining through the lower part of
the image to see the hidden material so
this is the first image and this is the
second image I selected the
or part of the second image copied it
and pasted it on to the first image so
that we have a sort of photo
illustration which you're going to see
more of next week in that we will show
what it is without the laser and what it
is with the lasers side by side
comparing the two with the information
in the caption the idea was to make the
cover and we did which was nice I think
it worked well you know some images look
even better when they are made into
covers with the addition of text they
might not be spectacular on their own
but often in my opinion are enhanced
with well-placed text as what happens
here this is not a very exciting image
that I made it's a detail of equipment
that's used in this particular lab I was
delighted that they liked the abstract
quality of the image and used it well in
fact with good placement of text in this
image I was working on some print
material for what was then called the
DuPont MIT Alliance which funded
research about bio inspired material I
made a picture of a sea urchin which is
a fascinating story in itself I made it
straight on I also tried it with the
flatbed scanner in the end the very
talented graphic designer he created a
pretty stunning brochure place the
scanner image on the cover and it worked
well in terms of the whole design of the
brochure and in this image which was
also part of the same project a
bioreactor where liver cells grow in
three-dimensional space I did like the
picture as I made it but once again the
graphic designer took it to another
level using the image as is and also
associating it on the page with a
drawing of the same reactor a very
interesting way of reinforcing the
structure for our book no small matter I
made a photograph of beer the idea was
to kill
sitter the molecular or nanostructure of
bubbles now notice that I include the
wall of the rectangular container in
image on the right the final cover
wrapped the image around the full book
and use the container area as the front
book flap which i think is kind of cool
here's an image you've seen before and
here it's used in the title page of the
Chinese version of our book no small
matter and here's the american title
page again just showing you how
photographs can be used with text once
again dropping text I think can make an
okay image which this is of bubbles into
a more interesting cover the left side
is the back cover of this booklet I
think that worked pretty well and this
photograph is a straight highly
documentary image showing the presence
of material in an assay and I simply use
the image in a more expanded idea for a
cover illustratively giving more
information about the material I don't
use illustrator very often but in this
case it seemed to work and finally here
is another image you've seen before used
both as a cover and back cover for an
MIT publication I was quite pleased that
the image i made fifteen years ago still
had a life frankly because of the
importance of nanocrystal or quantum
dots science yeah the picture was good
but the science is even better if you
are lucky to work with researchers whose
work is timeless then your photographs
might become timeless as well if you are
lucky